c'est au lycée de digoin que leur
aventure a débuté
théodore et sa fidèle assistante eva ont
réalisé ici à tout juste 18 ans leur
premier court métrage c'est des super
bons souvenirs création toute ma vie en
fait donc ça c'est formidable heures son
meilleur ami donc forcément je l'ait
soutenu dès le début du climat qu'il a
eu l'idée en fait dès le début j'étais
avec lui je les ai aidés etc et pour moi
c'est aussi une cause importante
cette cause c'est la lutte contre
l'homophobie
durant les 22 minutes de son court
métrage le jeune digoinais raconte la
vie de quatre adolescents tous
homosexuels confronter au regard de
leurs proches vous pourrissent la vie de
votre fils je vote car ils n'ont pas
d'argent là dedans et à la réticence
d'une société cantonner à des clichés
tenant a été attirée par ce gars t'es
amoureux ça veut dire que tu fantasmes
sur moi arrête de dire n'importe quoi
vraiment ce film financé en grande
partie par des fonds publics
comptabilise déjà plus d'un million de
vues sur youtube une fierté pour
théodore qui a écrit tourné et même
monter l'ensemble de son court métrage
faut tenir faut avoir les épaules mais
quand on a le résultat comme ça c'est le
positif au final c'est là qu'on se dit
ouais ok on sait pourquoi on l'a fait
cet adolescent s'est engagé pour cette
cause car il a été témoin d'actes
homophobes dans son entourage
inconcevable pour lui j'ai besoin de
m'exprimer
sur des sujets qui me semble vraiment
plus normaux aujourd'hui donc
l'homophobie ça n'aurait pu exister le
sexisme non plus toutes ces
discriminations qui sont totalement
ridicules en fait
théodore thomass a déjà écrit une suite
à son court métrage
le tournage doit débuter fin août de
bonne augure pour celui qui se prête à
rêver à une carrière au cinéma